i was reading about your life you know
doing some preparation for you
the big defining thing is that your mom
was gay and she came out of the closet
was it the defining thing for you as a
kid
i was 25. oh you were older that's even
more money it's weird yeah it's [ __ ]
weird you go in your head and you say i
never really knew my mother yes yeah
it's like a different person yeah and
she said too that she never ever she'd
just put it away and like just kind of
locked it up and did she divorce your
dad and say listen i i've i've realized
something
was your dad devastated oh yeah he was
really in love with her yeah do you
think she knew she always was gay and no
she lived a closeted life she said that
when my sister was born who's two years
younger
yeah oh god and she got married really
fast too like she met my dad not that
that's bad i mean my wife and i got
married really fast but
so your mom now does she have a
girlfriend or uh she's been with the
same woman that she left my father do
you like the woman wow yeah they're very
happy were you difficult in terms of the
adjustment did you give your mother [ __ ]
or did you say i can't deal with this
no
i i
felt like i could deal with it right and
i don't think i dealt with it very well
for a while because
you know growing up we always thought
that we were the perfect
family three kids suburbia
i never saw my parents fight wow ever
and and
but
and then it's all like then everything
is quite questionable it's a lie
it's a complete lie and so then i've had
to like kind of go back and slowly just
parse through it and like oh yeah she
used to sleep for like three hours in
the afternoon like she was severely
depressed right you know yeah she had to
be yeah i mean you know and you say she
left your dad for another woman that's
right yeah so she fell in love with
somebody yeah well she met they met in
seminary
my mother
yeah
that's another thing that my mother's
like i look back on it now and she would
get really intensely into religion right
for long periods
you know and i was like oh now it's like
obviously just searching for something
right and right this was one of those
periods where she was really into it and
she was going to become a minister wow
and she met this woman there and they
yeah they fell in love there i remember
you know that whole story likely how
that all went down well i remember my
dad my dad called me once i was living
here i was in brooklyn and he called me
up and he was like
and they'd been having trouble they were
in therapy together and reading
my dad was just quoting he would he'd
quote men are from mars women are from
venus
he's like really rob it's it's like
we're from different planets
yeah i mean there's a venus think about
it
and uh poor him because he might be so
he's trying yeah he was working his ass
off you weren't living home at that
point when your mom had to turn to your
dad and say hey listen and probably they
were in therapy listen i'm i'm gay my
brother was living at home he was yeah
and he was just graduating oh she did it
she called me up at work and she was
like will you uh will you come home i
was planning on coming home for my
father's birthday in two weeks
and she was like will you come home
this saturday instead which was father's
day right
and so i was like oh yeah sure
oh okay and then i some reason it
clicked right then i was like oh my god
she's gay and she's breaking up with my
father and this is the family meeting oh
and all my friends are like
you're
crazy what are you imagining
and uh and then sure enough she picked
father's day i mean you know it was a
convenient time to get us all together
oh that is crazy and uh and then she got
us together and she she uh it was in the
family our little living room and she
she
told us all and your dad was sitting
there oh yeah it was uh i've never you
mean he he didn't know
he didn't no he knew he knew this oh
okay this wasn't the first time he was
hearing no but it was raw it was it just
happened to him right now and so they
uh and he i've never seen my dad cry
before or since and
and when i said cry he cried and it was
just that
that was one of the most devastating
parts
seeing him so
hurt would have been great though if you
were inappropriate go oh my god this is
so hot this is going to be a great story
someday yeah i can't wait to get on the
howard stern draw and talk about it
you